the nuclear envoys of the US Japan and
South Korea sit down and soulle in
what's been a tense week on the Korean
peninsula in a policy address on Monday
North Korean leader Kim jungan declared
the status of its new foreign Enemy
Number One South Korea should be
codified in the Constitution and quote
subjugated and reclaimed in the event of
War preceding it on Sunday the test
firing of an intermediate ballistic
missile claimed to be tipped with a
hypersonic Warhead that coming as North
Korea also known as a democratic
People's Republic of Korea or dprk
transitions its missiles to more
difficult to detect solid fuel engines
guard posts and artillery have been put
back along the demilitarized zone the
dprk's continued development of its
unlawful nuclear and ballistic missile
programs its transfer of ballistic
missiles and other weapons to Russia for
use against Ukraine all of this demands
our attention and coordinated action as
pyongyang's top Diplomat cheson wrapped
her Moscow Mission this week the cremin
said they're developing relations in all
areas including quote sensitive ones a
reciprocal visit by Russian President
Vladimir Putin to North Korea is being
planned the ministry in charge of inter
Korean Affairs here says more military
agreements appear to have been agreed
with chz visit Soul estimates some 5,000
containers a ble to hold millions of
artillery shells were sent to Russia
last year Washington says North Korean
ballistic missiles are already being
used by Russian forces in Ukraine back
on the peninsula South Korean president
Yun maintains North Korea's provocations
will be met in kind and
manyfold but this North Korean scholar
says there needs to be a
shift as a divided nation South Korea is
deter power against the north is crucial
but the UN government needs a policy
shift that balances deterrence and
dialogue maintaining diplomacy relying
on the US Alliance but not neglecting
cooperation with China South Korea Japan
and the US take the North Korea matter
to a closed door United Nations security
Council session on Thursday where all
three are members this year Unis Kim Al
jazer soul